bienvenidos de nuevo quiero disculparme
porque en el último problema estaba
cerca del límite de tiempo que me da
youtube y siento que me apresuré un poco
para realizar la solución pero lo
importante es que me lo haga saber
mándame un mensaje en ese vídeo si crees
que no entendiste la solución del último
problema o si crees que la explicación
no fue la óptima o te sentiste
confundido es importante que tengamos
una buena comunicación una vez dicho
esto vamos a hacer el siguiente problema
el problema número 9 así que vamos a
trabajar con el problema número 9 que
dice lo siguiente por cierto este
problema está en la página en 461 la
parte decimal de este número y nos pone
en un número déjame apuntar todo aquí
5.101 2 021 tres ceros
a 1402 y así sigue y sigue y sigue este
número muy bien la parte decimal de este
número sólo contiene unos y ceros a la
derecha del punto decimal al primer uno
le sigue un 0 al segundo uno le siguen
dos ceros al primero uno le sigue un 0
al segundo 12 ceros al tercer 13 ceros
al cuarto 4 ceros y así sigue y bueno
que nos preguntan cuál es la cantidad de
ceros que hay entre 98º 1 y el 101º 1 es
decir queremos saber la cantidad de
ceros de ceros que hay
hay entre el 198 entre el 198
vamos a ponerlo como en una g simon
octavo y el 1 101 es decir el 101º yo
quiero saber cuántos ceros hay entre
estos dos unos entonces esencialmente lo
que hay que ver es cuánto ceros hay
después del 98º 1 es decir del 198
cuántos ceros hay después del 99º 1 es
decir del 199 y cuántos ceros hay
después del centésimo 1 es decir de unos
100 porque porque si yo me fijo después
en el 101º 1 es decir en este la
cantidad de ceros que hay después de
este 1 ya no me importan ya no me
importa la cantidad de ceros que hay
porque fíjate bien yo lo que quiero
saber es la cantidad de ceros que hay
entre el 98º
y el 101º 1 la cantidad que está en
medio entonces si yo estoy en el primer
1 después de ese 1 hay un cero si yo
estoy en el segundo uno hay dos ceros en
el tercero no hay tres ceros
si estoy en el décimo uno hay 10 ceros
después de ese 1 sí estoy en el 24º 1
después de ese 1 va a haber 24 ceros
si estoy en el n abono después de ese 1
va a haber en ceros y bueno regresando a
esta misma idea de después del 98º uno
va a haber 98 ceros
después del 1 que está en la posición 99
es decir del 99º uno va a haber 99 ceros
y después del centésimo uno va a haber
100 ceros fíjate bien tendríamos algo
por el estilo yo tengo aquí mi punto
decimal y después hay un 1 y después hay
muchos ceros y unos muchos muchos muchos
hasta que llegamos a un 1
uno es el que está en mi posición 98 el
98º y después de este uno va a haber un
cero y muchos muchos ceros hasta que
lleguemos a un cero y después otra vez a
un uno pero nosotros sabemos que esta
cantidad de ceros que hay de aquí acá
son 98 porque recuerda que después del 1
que está en una cierta posición va a ver
la cantidad de ceros de la posición en
la que va a estar entonces si estamos en
la posición 98 vamos a tener 98 ceros y
este uno esté 1 es mi 1 que está en la
posición 99 mi nona g simon noveno y
después de él va a haber un cero muchos
muchos muchos ceros hasta que digamos
otra vez un cero y después vamos a
llegar a un 1 y que cree eso de aquí y
hasta acá
tú sabes cuántos ceros hay después del
199 debe de haber 99 ceros y por fin
contamos todos estos ceros y llegamos al
1 100 es decir al centésimo 1 y después
del centésimo uno va a haber por cierto
aquí
50 vamos a ponerlo para que no te
confundas después de este centésimo uno
va a haber un cero y también una
cantidad muy grande de ceros hasta que
lleguemos otra vez a un cero y a un 1 y
la cantidad de ceros que va a haber de
aquí hasta acá son 100 ceros y este es
mi 1 101 este es mi 1 101 y después de
este 1 101 claro que hay 101 ceros sin
embargo ya no me importa porque yo lo
que quiero saber es la cantidad de ceros
que hay entre este 1 y entre este 1 es
decir esta cantidad de ceros
esta cantidad de ceros esta cantidad de
ceros que esencialmente es la suma de 98
99 más 100 y la suma de 98 99 más 100
esto es lo mismo que el 9 y 8 son 17 y
llevamos una 99 y una y una me quedan 30
entonces 300 70 saber entre máximo 8º 1
y me 101º 1
y este es el inciso
no espera no está 307 aquí hay algo raro
hice bien la suma vamos a ver
8 y 9 son 7 17 llevamos 1 9 y 1 son 10 y
9 2 y el 9 son 19 y 10 son 29 no perdón
no son 307 son 297 la cantidad de ceros
que debe de haber entre el 98º 1 y el
101º 1 y esta sí están mis respuestas
por lo tanto me siento ya con más
confianza y mejor vamos a hacer el
siguiente problema que es el problema el
número 10 así que déjenme borrar este
pizarrón y vámonos al siguiente problema
el problema número 10 y el problema
número 10 que me dice este es un
problema de funciones dice que fx fx es
igual a 3 - 2x cuadradas esto dividido
entre x
x distinto de 0 y lo que me preguntan es
cuánto vale efe de 2 cuánto vale efe de
2 y bueno esencialmente lo que hay que
hacer es reemplazar a x por 2 ponerlo en
este lugar así que vamos a sustituir a x
por 2 y que me va a quedar que f de y
voy a cambiar de color para que veas de
dónde salió
efe de 2 quienes efe de 2 bueno pues
sustituyendo a x por 2 en esta función
me va a quedar tres menos dos por equis
cuadrada pero esto es lo mismo que por
dos elevado al cuadrado porque ene efe
de 2x vale 2
efe de 2 esto elevado al cuadrado entre
x pero x vale 2 y cuantos esto bueno
pues esto es lo mismo que 3 - 2 x 2 x 2
es 83 menos 8 entre 2 y esto es
exactamente lo mismo que menos
medios 5 medios y esta es la respuesta
del problema 10 ya está que por cierto
es el inciso d y el siguiente problema
el problema número 11 es un problema de
geometría así que no creo que me quema
en esta parte y mejor vamos a borrar el
pizarrón y vamos a poner aquí el
problema número 11 que dice lo siguiente
íbamos a hacer la figura que está por
aquí para esto necesito esta herramienta
muy bien tengo una línea más o menos así
tengo otra línea más o menos así pero
esta línea es perpendicular así que más
o menos le voy a poner por acá y después
tengo una línea que parece ser
perpendicular a esta pero me parece que
no es perpendicular la voy a poner algo
algo así porque realmente no es
perpendicular a esta línea que por
cierto me dan el nombre esta línea se
llama n este ángulo si es perpendicular
esta esta línea se llama l estar acá se
llama m y además tengo que este ángulo
es x grados y este ángulo es de 10
grados y bueno lo que me dice el
problema es lo siguiente en la figura
siguiente la recta en la recta l son
perpendiculares aquí están aquí los
tenemos perpendiculares y además el
ángulo x es mayor de 90 grados
perfecto es decir que este ángulo es más
grande que de 90 grados y por lo tanto
estas dos rectas no son perpendiculares
muy bien lo que me preguntan es cuál de
las siguientes afirmaciones es verdadera
y el primer inciso me dice que es menor
que 90 grados y creo que esta es la
respuesta correcta fíjate bien si yo
tengo aquí una recta
porque esta es mi recta n entonces esto
es un acta n y por acá cruza mi recta m
entonces vamos a ponerles nombres esta
es mi recta en esta es muy recta m por
lo tanto este de aquí es mi ángulo x que
es mayor de 90 grados y este de aquí es
mi ángulo james y lo que queremos saber
es qué es lo que pasa con james entonces
lo primero que quiero que te des cuenta
es que x y james son ángulos
suplementarios equis y jenson ángulos
suplementarios porque juntos forman un
ángulo de 90 grados es decir que x +
james tiene que ser igual a 180 grados x
media tiene que ser igual a 180 grados y
aquí el insistir me dice que ya es menor
que 90 grados si x es más grande que 90
grados
entonces ya tiene que ser un ángulo
menor que 90 grados de tal manera que la
suma de los dos me de 180 grados
imagínate si yo fuera igual a 90 grados
entonces algo más grande que 90 grados
más algo de 90 grados me va a dar algo
más grande que 180 grados porque 90
grados es la mitad de esto y si que
fuera más grande que 90 grados entonces
algo más grande que 90 grados más algo
más grande que 90 grados pues en
definitiva no me va a dar 180 grados por
lo tanto el inciso am parís es la
respuesta correcta que dice que ya es
menor que 90 grados y vamos a ver los
otros incisos para realmente estar
seguros de nuestra respuesta el si sube
dice que es igual a 90 grados eso no
puede ser cierto porque entonces la suma
no me daría 180 grados el inciso se me
dice que ya es mayor que 90 grados en
definitiva no se nota que ya no es un
ángulo mayor que 90 grados
recuerda que si fuera mayor o igual a 90
grados
entonces x más jim sería mayor que 180
grados y después el inciso te me dice n
es perpendicular a m
es perpendicular m en definitiva no si
este ángulo de 90 grados entonces esta
recta no va a ser perpendicular recuerda
que para que dos rectas son
perpendiculares todos sus ángulos que se
forman deben de ser de 90 grados
y por último me dice l es paralela m por
la misma razón eso no puede ser cierto
si no cruzan en el mismo ángulo entonces
estas rectas no son paralelas tarde o
temprano se van a cruzar muy bien
entonces creo que me da tiempo de hacer
el siguiente problema así que vamos a
trabajar en el el problema número 12 así
que vamos a hacerlo por acá en el plano
x james así que pues nada nos cuesta
hacer un plano por aquí voy a hacer mi
plano xy por aquí este es mi eje series
por aquí tengo nuestro me gustó por aquí
tengo mi eje de las x dice en el plano
xy la función ye igual a 5 x menos 10
vamos a apuntar la
igual a 5 x menos diez cruzan al eje de
las x en el punto y coma de entonces
vamos a apuntar eso cruza al eje de las
x en el punto coma b
este es el punto donde cruza al eje de
las x cruza al eje x muy bien entonces
lo que me preguntan es cuánto vale a
cuánto vale a esto es lo que yo quiero
saber éste es un eje de las 'íes' esto
es un eje de las equis y bueno si
nosotros observamos esta función de una
manera rápida nos podemos dar cuenta que
esta es una recta es decir es una recta
que se ve más o menos así esta es mi
recta y de igual a 5 x más 10 y esta
recta cruza tarde o temprano al eje x va
a cruzar justo aquí al eje x en el punto
y coma sin embargo quiero que te des
cuenta que cuando una función cruz
al eje de las equis estamos diciendo que
la coordenada en game vale 0 es decir
que siempre que tengamos una función y
esta función cruce a mi eje de las x
date cuenta que ya en este punto va a
valer cero por lo tanto b vale cero o
dicho de otra manera ya vale cero en
este punto y si lleva de cero me va a
quedar la ecuación cero igual a 5 x
menos 10 sustituyendo este valor en
ecuación original y de aquí ya podemos
despejar la x
si yo paso este 10 del otro lado me va a
quedar que 5x es igual a 10 positivo
sumando 10 de ambos lados de la ecuación
y después he vivido todo en 35 dividido
todo entre 5 me va a quedar que x es
igual a 2 es decir que en este punto
donde mi función cruza al eje de las x
le vale 0 y x vale 2
estamos en el punto 20 y por lo tanto a
vale 2 que por cierto es
y ya está aquí tenemos el problema
número 12 y el siguiente problema está
involucrado con una tabla así que nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo cuídate
mucho